human worries on occasion but for some
of us the suffering is on a quite
different and more life-destroying scale
we are without wishing to be ungrateful
or absurd more or less permanently
anxious what makes matters so hard for
us the anxious is that we're unable to
maintain a distinction between what
objectively deserves terror and what
automatically an unthinking Lee provokes
terror the quintessential calming
question is there actually anything to
be scared of here can't even enter
consciousness there's no sense that a
benign response could even be possible
easily terrified people aren't stupid
they may even be among the brightest
it's just that somewhere in their
history the mental equipment designed to
distinguish logically between relative
dangers has been destroyed they have
somewhere along the line received such a
very big fright that pretty much
everything has now grown frightening
every slightly daunting challenge
becomes a harbinger of the end there are
no more gradations the party where one
knows no one the speech to delegates the
tricky conversation at work these can
put the whole of existence into question
pretty much every day
is a crisis let's go in for a metaphor
imagine that at a formative moment when
the anxious would have been profoundly
unprepared and without the resources to
cope they had an encounter with a bear
the bear was beyond terrifying it raged
it stamped it crushed it threatened to
destroy everything it was
incomprehensible mind defying ly awful
as a result the anxious person's inner
alarm jammed into the on position and a
state stuck there ever since there is no
use casually telling this person that
there aren't any bears around at the
moment or that this isn't the season or
that most bears are kind or that campers
rarely encounter them that's easy for
you to say you who's never woken up with
a giant grizzly staring at you with
incisors showing and giant paws clasped
open for the kill the result of this
bearing
counter is an unconscious commitment to
catastrophic generalization the anxious
fear of all bears but also all dogs
rabbits mice and squirrels and all
campsites and all sunny days and even
associated things like trees rustling in
the wind or prairie grass or the smell
of coffee that was being made shortly
before the bear showed up the anxious
can't do logical distinctions they can't
arrange threats in two separate boxes to
start to dig ourselves out of the
quicksand of worry we the anxious need
to do something that's likely to feel
very artificial and probably a bit
patronizing too we need to learn on
occasion to distrust our senses
completely these senses that are mostly
terrific guides to life have to be seen
for what they also are profoundly
unreliable instruments capable of
throwing out faulty readings and
destroying our lives we need to erect a
firm distinction between feelings and
reality to grasp that an impression is
not a prognosis and a fear is not a fact
one side of the mind has to treat the
other with a robust kindly skepticism I
know you're sure there's a bear out
there at that party or in that newspaper
article or in that office meeting but is
there one really really really emotion
will be screaming yes like one's life
depends on it
but we've been here before and we need
with infinite forbearance to let the
screaming go on a little and ignore it
entirely the cure lies in watching the
panic unfold and refusing to get
involved in its seeming certainties we
need to be like a pilot of a
sophisticated aeroplane coming in to
land in deep fog on autopilot
the pilots senses may tell them that a
dreadful collision is imminent but their
reason knows that the sums have been
done correctly and that a smooth landing
is despite the darkness and the awful
vibrations definitely about to unfold to
get better which really means to stop
dreading bears everywhere we need to
spend more time thinking about the
specific bear that we once saw
the impasse is to focus always on the
fear of the future but we need instead
to direct our minds back to the past and
revisit the damaging scenes with
compassion and in kindly company a
consequence of not knowing the details
of what once scared us is a fear of
everything into the future
so we should ask what sort of bear was
it what did it do to us how did we feel
we need to re localize and repatriate
the bear to get to know it as a specter
that happened to us at one point in one
place so that it can stop haunting us
everywhere for all time that we were
once very scared is our historical
tragedy the challenge from now on is to
stop giving ourselves ever new reasons
to ruin the rest of our lives with fear
we can learn the skill of being calm not
through specialties or slow breathing
but through thinking our book guides us
through that process click to find out
more